lo que haremos en este vídeo será
ejercitar la comparación de números
representados de diferentes maneras por
ejemplo del lado izquierdo
tenemos 0.37 aunque también lo podemos
ver como 37 centésimas y del lado
derecho
tenemos 307 milésimas lo que quiero que
hagan ahorita es que pausa en el vídeo y
analicen si estas dos cantidades son
iguales o una es más grande que la otra
cual es más grande y cuál es más pequeña
pausa en el vídeo y traten de descubrir
bueno vamos a resolverlo juntos la forma
en que mi cerebro funciona es que
primero trato de poner las dos
cantidades en una representación común
así que una manera de resolverlo es
tratando de reescribir esta cantidad de
la derecha como un decimal
vamos a reescribir este número que nos
está expresando una cierta cantidad de
milésimas pero primero pondré a los
espacios esta es la posición de las
unidades después tenemos el punto
decimal después tenemos la posición
de las décimas esta es la posición de
las centésimas y esta es la posición de
las milésimas
si tenemos 307 milésimas eso quiere
decir que tenemos 307 de este lugar así
que simplemente escribimos el 7 aquí 0 y
esto representa 307 milésimas y no
tenemos unidades
entonces si analizamos esta cantidad y
la comparamos con esta es más fácil
ahora que tenemos esta forma porque
podemos decir bueno tenemos el mismo
número en las unidades tenemos el mismo
número en las décimas voy a remarcar
nuestras décimas son iguales pero qué
pasa cuando llegamos a las centésimas
observen que aquí tenemos siete
centésimas pero aquí tenemos cero
centésimas así que el número de la
izquierda es el más grande 37 centésimas
son más grandes que 307 milésimas otra
forma en la que podríamos haberlo hecho
sería expresando este número de la
izquierda
en términos de milésimas es decir que en
lugar de 37 centésimas podríamos haberlo
escrito como 0.37 y simplemente ponemos
otro cero a la derecha
estas son 370 milésimas lo escribiré 370
milésimas
entonces cuando lo vemos de esta forma
podemos ver claramente que 370 de algo
es más que 307 de ese algo por eso la
cantidad de la izquierda es más grande
hagamos otro ejemplo pero esta vez usaré
diferentes formatos supongamos que del
lado izquierdo voy a usar la forma
décima aquí tenemos 0.6 o 6 décimas y
del lado derecho tenemos 6 x 1 / 100
pausa en el vídeo y díganme cuál de
estas cantidades es mayor o si son
iguales
bueno nuevamente para resolverlo
necesitamos pensar en cuáles son las
diferentes formas en las que podemos
representar a estos números y tratar de
expresarlos de la misma forma entonces
voy a reescribir seis décimas como seis
por un décimo seis por un décimo y tal
vez esto sea suficiente para comparar
las dos cantidades porque seis por un
décimo será mayor
o igual a 6 por 1 centésima bueno un
décimo es diez veces más grande que un
centésimo entonces si esto es diez veces
más grande que esto al multiplicar por
seis esta será una cantidad más grande
podemos decir que esta cantidad es más
grande que es otra forma en la que nos
pudimos haber dado cuenta habría sido
expresando esta cantidad de la derecha
en decimal como ésta entonces si esto es
seis veces un centésima por seis
centésimas estas son las unidades estas
son las décimas y después en la posición
de las centésimas es en donde tenemos
seis y si todavía no es obvio que esto
es menor a esto simplemente podemos
agregar un cero aquí y ahora lo leemos
como 60 centésimas y está claro que 60
centésimas son más grandes que 6
centésimas entonces todas estas son
formas razonables de representar los
números y escribirlos en el mismo
formato para compararlos
así nos dimos cuenta que
en este caso en los dos ejemplos las
cantidades de la izquierda son mayores a
las de la derecha